is this where you used to play yeah man
this is we used to do football tryouts
here oh it's so surreal being back
um yeah it's like it's so weird because
I was little when I was here so it feels
um like so much smaller than I remember
oh yes well back when I was you know 5'3
running around trying to be on the
football team so this is everything
yeah but you came to the park with some
real experience though yeah yeah it took
me a while though I failed the first try
out something like Stronger Yeah yeah
I've been out to play basketball for a
little bit the basketball team was just
like made up of all the kids that
couldn't be on the football team and
then um yeah I had my Redemption story
and I came back what position did you
play basketball
I think I honestly it just got to a
point where it was like just just run
around and dribble the ball you know how
old were you when you meant it when you
made the team oh man
um probably like
13 14 you know we used to like run
around
um play football after school and then
um and we'd have tournaments we didn't
win a lot of them but um we did win this
like one five aside tournament and we
went and we won that and that's the only
thing we won and um I remember I went
crazy and I used to wear my medal to
school every single day in the next two
weeks
yeah it was fun were you a good soccer
player I got better I got better like
what I lacked in um actual skill and
talent I made up for in in hard work
yeah and running yeah you know good
enough to pull it off on the screen oh
yeah definitely but then I also got I
got better as I got older so by the time
it came time to do tabasso I was um a
supernatural Talent that's not what I
say that's what other people say about
me I'm sure if you asked the other
classmates that yeah they'd use those
words specifically Supernatural
Supernatural I'm gonna flop now because
I'm on camera but uh
yeah
this was your stage this was my stage I
did all of all of my rehearsals here I
did all of my performances here like I
lived in this room this was like the
birthplace of like me wanting to be a
performer he wanted to be an actor this
was my safe haven this is one of my
teachers hello Martin blakelock um this
is the man I used to force I used to
like sit you down over here and just
like yell Shakespeare at you I remember
you did up there
up there Marc Anthony yeah
that was
that was a chance
he says you changed his life that's very
nice thank you do you remember that time
like you pulled me into your office and
like you sat me down and you were like I
think you can you can like um
hello
oh my God I always cry when I'm on the
stage genuinely
um
I had a really like profound impact on
me and like I owe so much of what I am
doing now to you and and I'm like just I
can't thank you enough because you
didn't have to like you went above and
beyond for me you're welcome yeah I
appreciate it yeah
what did you see in him
do you know it's easy and it's hard to
say at the same time because I think you
see the talent and then it's we always
say to them then the hard work comes and
he has plenty of that as well so you
know not not always the best behaved at
all points throughout his school Journey
I've spent a lot of time in this room I
did
I did like even just being had now a lot
of memories are coming back yeah that's
crazy yeah once I decided like I wanted
to be an actor and like I'd found that I
just spent all of my time here how was
drama school
oh man drama school was it was really
cool it was really dope it was what I
wanted I wanted to be in a position
where I could act every day and do
nothing but act every single day
um and I got to do that I made some of
the best friends yeah you know
um that's how like people who will be in
my life for hopefully a very long time
yeah but um but I also had his
challenges you know
um I was coming from Inner City South
London to the Barbican estate yeah where
everybody you know earns more in his
alphabetical class probably and and you
know speaks with a different accent and
and it was just a complete culture shock
for me and at that time like drama
schools hadn't really they didn't really
have the best track record with um
accommodating black students yeah and so
that was that was tough I was like one
of four I think out of uh well like 26
you know and that's just in my year the
rest of the year it was just yeah it had
its challenges
um what was the most challenging part
for you
um I think that I think like really
feeling like I belonged there yeah
because I I made the switch to decide to
be an actor really late I was
about to go to university and then
suddenly I decided I wanted to do this
thing I didn't know anybody who was an
actor and so like I didn't have a I
didn't have like a famous Uncle I mean
some level that must have been scary but
on both counts that you don't one
that you you just suddenly made the
decision to be happier yeah and two you
end up in a school you don't see a lot
of people who look like you yeah so
you're like am I in the right place yeah
it's crazy but I think underneath all of
that was this thing that I really enjoy
doing my whole life has kind of been
about
like where I fit in I kind of felt like
I fell in between being a British kid
and being a Nigerian kid and never
really felt like a part of either club
and I feel like really recently
through all of these other like amazing
artists that I look up to yeah um
especially like in pop culture like
being a black Brit is kind of solidified
in my mind as its own thing and like
that's kind of where I feel at home a
bit you know like I like you see Daniel
Korea doing stuff and I go all right
cool I see myself in that like I see
stormzy doing stuff all Dave doing stuff
and I go I see myself and these people
and
um yeah like especially at a time when I
was at drama school where I felt like I
was
like being pulled in between like two
different places and I didn't really
know where to Center myself in in this
country like being a black Brit became
like my Saving Grace so your first
memories are in Nigeria yeah my first
accent was a Nigerian accent and
um so yeah again like it's really dope
because I get to play two Nigerian
characters in Simon tunde
um in what is actually my like first
voice you know so I always find it
really weird how now my career has taken
me back to the thing that I kind of like
got rid of to to fit in you know yeah
must have made your parents proud though
yeah yeah I think so my dad's like one
of the most stoic people ever so like I
could do anything I could win 14 Oscars
tomorrow and he'd just be like good
he's good yeah my mom always had an idea
that I was going to be the UK's first
black prime minister
um maybe I'll play him one day
that's that's not gonna happen I'm
curious when when you first when you
first read the Ted lasso script did you
think people would would embrace it I
don't think any of us went into it
thinking it would be what it is now but
what we made I thought was really
special and then it came out and people
got hold of it and it just like became
this whole other thing and I think we
were yeah we would just rode the Wave A
little yeah what's right in that wave
then like
um nuts that isn't crazy
um but in a good way you know like all
of our lives have changed did you know
the romance was coming in season two no
you didn't no nobody told me about that
we were reading the script and I was
like I see
um it was uh yeah it was um it was a bit
of a shock
um I remember Jason saying something
along the lines of oh like you know
we're gonna like explore like a romance
for some but I didn't think it was going
to be that like fans used to message me
and be like
uh after the locker room scene where Sam
tries to get her to come and do the the
ritual
um get rid of the ghosts yes
um and and they were like oh like is
there anything romantic or is it just
platonic and I was like honest but like
what the hell that never happened and um
but like I think what they hit on was
that there is a connection between those
two characters yeah and you two were
friends off screen as well yeah yeah
she's she's dope she's a rock star that
woman
um yeah and I think that's why I also
felt really comfortable about it it's
because yeah you know I just get to like
hang out with a friend so it was really
cool yeah
um tell me about the power
power
um the power is a really special project
for me it's a like a global Thriller
um set in this world where like women
and um young girls especially develop
the ability to release and generate
electricity through their hands
um so ultimately they become like
physically the superior gender almost
overnight you play a journalist who
discovers this yes I played Tinder who
kind of unknowingly breaks the story and
then before he knows it becomes a really
significant mouthpiece for this like for
these new Global events and um and yeah
like he's he's a really cool character
he's a Nigerian he's an aspiring
journalist and I just yeah he ends up I
think going on this like really
transformative Journey over the first
season the tunnel that you meet in
episode one The Sunday that you see in
episode nine is a completely different
person and and I think that really drew
me to it like I was really interested in
like what that version of like
masculinity or manhood look like in in
this new world and and like going on
this journey to help this young man find
it yeah yeah in the first episode so you
literally get a shock yeah yeah it's um
it's a really mind-boggling thing like
it poses really dope questions about
power and and you know who has it who
doesn't yeah pose really interesting
questions about the power dynamics
between men and women yeah but also like
I guess what's really interesting about
the power is that I get to like chart my
own Journey as an actor through it
because like I I know what was yeah free
pandemic what was post pandemic and and
what do you see when you see um I just I
feel more um comfortable I I'm not sure
I don't know if people will like notice
a difference
um but you see one I think I just know
what I was thinking when I was shooting
you know and um with Ted lasso and the
power I got like a really awesome
opportunity to just like grow and
develop and figure out what I wanted to
do and yeah and um and I can yeah I can
see the Cog standing a bit a bit more um
yeah and do you like what you see yeah
yeah I think it's really good yeah can
you imagine if I didn't I was like oh my
God
damn no um yeah I really enjoy it like I
see myself maturing in a similar way to
how my character's growing up in the
show I see myself growing up in the show
yeah and um and yeah like so just
because of the pandemic and stuff like I
get a really awesome opportunity to
chart that growth yeah yeah
well that must be satisfying it really
is I can't wait for people to see it I
can't wait to share it with people now
man um yeah that's gonna be a fun one